it's good take a long time for me to
forgive you for this one this looks so
good from the trailer he could have said
no my pain this is the worst it doesn't
get worse than I I couldn't agree more
this is literally the bottom of the
barrel yeah now I don't know what dark
Phoenix is gonna do but you know for now
this is literally the BA I will give
Dark Phoenix of a little bit of credit
it can't be as bad as this it just came
really difficult the best characters
Wolverine we all want to see Wolverine
clearly if they just you know take out
the middle x-man is so to speak and just
thinking about Wolverine I mean where we
can get something really cool LOB's in
it and stuff and I just can't believe
how much they mucked it up
Logan was a great movie so that proved
that you can do a Wolverine movie right
then the next Wolverine movie to me is
only okay yeah it just boobs still
better than this but what pisses me off
about the idea of we need another a
movie you had essentially three
Wolverine movies are with x-men x2 and
and last stand
I mean those are Wolverine movies with
x-men in them I haven't seen this sense
it came out and literally saw this on
the big screen surprisingly have not
seen it again no I am NOT and maybe
it'll give better pain I remember it
really hurts oh here we go this is years
and years since it came out x-men
origins Laurine I can't remember they do
the accent this one they do you can see
the little line around it I was gonna
say is that line always there I forget
around there no that's what every time
we've done one the x-men movies I'm like
you can tell because that X is inserted
[Laughter]
but the ends get turned upside down to
form a w a Marvel sub that's kind of the
makeup for it always sick you were sick
when you're my age Kate you pull there's
more dramatic than I remember it
still cold father is the mild fever mild
fever doesn't that like kill you and
that a I feel I feel like this is
exactly what Danny was talking about a
gamegrumps with that bit he has with the
father
we are often this for noon and there is
but one parachute but to us pretty
that's what we do
father I didn't bring my babies he just
got no as director no cuz look out there
he looks good he looks like every last
one yeah that's very comic book is that
kind of like that son tell you already
what bothers me about this I feel like
I'm watching some lesser vampire the way
no no the way they don't age this
opening replace claws with fangs this is
a freaking vampire movie dude it'll be
just as long and boring oh that's right
so many people I forget the reason
underneath one of them he's throwing
beautiful number 20 we need to keep a
low profile let's be in every single war
it's almost like he's all look like sets
from other movies Tropic Thunder Saving
Private Ryan yeah with three minutes in
it already feels like three hours and I
compare leave for God's the opening dead
he killed his father and everything I'm
just like man isn't that amazing how
much that just like forgot I was like oh
yeah like that happened and that's
supposed to like carry through I'm sure
now we're on to the next bullshit I mean
it's like what what character
development did we get apart from over
time Sabretooth just goes psycho
we got asking where he found it heavy
fun fact Deadpool speaks in Nigeria of
course he does also I know the idea he's
supposed to be younger he's supposed to
be tougher but do you for a second think
oh yeah that's Brian Cox's character
he's gonna go on to be Brian kind oh wow
he's living right next to Captain Kirk
in the Nexus I don't know I have no
motivation in this movie
yeah let's make fun of him because he's
getting salmon we got none dead right
there just under that smile ding it's
like I've watched this and I'm just
amazed that Logan ever got made
it is just so dull why do I give a shit
about any of it they haven't told you
anything about this yeah
just a reminder I'll be dead soon well
we gotta get out of here she's gonna die
frankly I'm a little disappointed so are
we we've seen all this yeah like in
numerous flashbacks it's like here we go
again but uh now we know the story now
we can connect all that we know about
them all kind of one thing I like to
give the needles drilling the liquid
into the by kind of like that like
that's the one thing I don't know if
they show it so it's just like it
happened it was under water it was
surgery I like oh there's a heartbeat
but the movies brain-dead oh my god it's
a May and Uncle Ben oh no it's the
Kemp's rah oh that's right come across
spider-man Superman and we'll hurry I
just came from the future I'm a
terminator wow those look bad oh my god
that looks like from Roger Rabbit
remember like the bending sword I hope
you're not javelin and CGI in there
that's the gateway drug to bad special
effects can't thank you both enough
probably
I'm Jonathan expendable this is Martha
expendable
read me a story movie of the week first
we beam x-men origins movie but I won't
do that
looks like he's fighting an apple with
arms and legs so way he found glasses at
that age to control his powers like wow
that's terrible
wait a minute they let Vegas and they're
gonna come across gambit what would make
more sense we found gambit in Vegas
that's a trip yeah
wouldn't it be cooler if he was in Vegas
just had to be a Cajun guy in Vegas oh I
like this Gallatin disappeared that's
actually kind of cool yeah because I
know who you are again but you said the
name here that makes sense if you're
gonna have one cool shiny tire film it
belongs to gambit it's like fair enough
okay it's not fair enough they should
all be good shots and this should be a
good movie but still
Oh smells like a hologram going through
his hand didn't even benefit to kill you
just what you tell me about the island
I'm Jimmy oh is that the Sun is that a
better
oh yeah cuz everything else ties back in
so beautifully how do you get away with
just murdering a five-star general yeah
nobody at the CIA nobody is gonna be
like he gets to talk to the president
later get this thing anyway oh this is
my face yeah I wanna earn a game Jackie
over five I'm just gonna say it
damn it's not great the the bar was so
lowered that we remember being greater
than he was cuz yeah yeah but like now
that I'm listening to his performance
I'm like it's not really that great
he's almost McConaughey get a few more
out and he will respond to my commands
were forcing him to keep his eyes open
we wanted to see the whole movie that's
pretty much what they wanted to do to
the audience of this film
so our mouths shut and then keep our
eyes wide open the whole time Clockwork
Orange style hey sorry I know we had
something for like two minutes of screen
time did they and I ignored my instincts
I know won't ever happen again I'm gonna
be a Logan none of you people are gonna
be remembered except for Brian Reynolds
that's fucked up think about that for a
second hey you've got spy cowboy bebop
here that's awesome what can you say to
this book Ryan Reynolds said in the
trailer yeah I'm the same people who
thought it was a great idea to so
Deadpool's mouth shut it's like talk
about Jar Jar Biggs yeah what else can
you possibly say yeah but it's cool
because at least he's in the Deadpool
uniform hallway if nobody even told you
that was Deadpool which you know nobody
would know you know here's something you
can say that I'm sure people keep saying
but it's like it really is just so
impressive that Ryan Reynolds took
everything around this character and
made this brand-new movie he still
starred as it
that's really something it's just all
the more pressing right really a key
part yeah
you know Jonathan trice is getting
tortured by Michael Palin Homer Simpson
opens the door that doing a break oops
sorry wrong room
just like the real tip oh yeah
baseball's time to get out of this movie
they kiss its mystique again for no
dessert actually fuck you just got the
cooler twisted how cool would that be a
ghost misty the whole time
holy shit you're safe now how much want
bet they just used the CG from last damn
they didn't even hire magic Stewart they
just totally use that but it's okay
because any other x-men films when they
ask him what do you remember
he totally says yeah I woke up in an
exploded nuclear power plant with this
Cajun guy lording over me saying that
the kids are safe wow that's interesting
that sounds like the night I met those
kids and brought them to my you're so
sad who put together this story and
script Direction sucks - but it's like
story there's no way you can make this
story good yeah you'd have to really
really really rewrite this it could have
made the action more interesting there's
things you could have worked around but
it still would've been bad yeah yeah
what is stupid nothing a whole bunch of
nothing it's it's nothing and then when
you think about its wrongful it's oh man
oh that only got worse
I got worse I can't even say good no
it's exact same reaction I had the first
time which is fucking socks should have
builded x-men
Norwich ins am i right origins it's
something I hate this movie so much
right I just died you need the police
okay you know why it sucks but you know
its value do we yeah ditalion yeah
that's about it easily the worst one at
least there's no debating Ted so uh
we'll see you the next one guys take
care
fucking trash
you